hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast inventing active surveillance
version 2.0 I'm Brenda Kelly Kim of
labroots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's webcast is
presented by lab roots.com the leading
social media site for science
Professionals for more information
please visit us at
www.ab
roots.com before we start there are a
few instructions we want to hear from
you during this interactive broadcast so
please ask question or leave us a
comment answers are welcome too you can
do this by hitting the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up with you if
we don't have time today want a better
look you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you can't hear or see this presentation
properly please let us know by clicking
on the support button on the top right
or use the Q&A button we'll make sure we
try to resolve any issues this
presentation has been approved for
continuing educational credits if you
want to obtain the credits please click
on the get your free CME C credits
button located in the lower left of your
screen this will take you to a page
listing all of our speakers and
presentations please select the C CME
button under the presentation and follow
the instructions to claim your
certificate now let's get right to
today's presenter we are proud to
welcome Dr Eric Klein MD he's the
chairman of the Glickman neurological
and kidney Institute and a staff member
in the tosic Cancer Institute at
Cleveland Clinic his clinical interests
are Cancers of the prostate testes and
kidney for several years including the
current edition Dr Klein is listed in
best doctors in America for more
information about Dr Klein please click
on his name to learn more about his
background I'll now turn it over to Dr
Klein for his
presentation thank you and good
afternoon everybody thank you for
joining us the subtitle of my talk is
prostate cancer in the era of precision
medicine we have evolved to the point
where in almost every clinical decision
we make in prostate cancer we have
molecular data available to us to guide
our decisions and precision medicine is
defined as making a specific management
decision or treatment decision or choice
of drug based on the individual ual
molecular characteristics of an
individual's tumor today I'm going to be
talking about the use of the Precision
medicine approach and what might be
called active surveillance version 2.0
or next Generation active
surveillance and excuse me I'm having a
little difficulty advancing my slides
here here we go let me start with my
disclosures I work with many of the
companies that have worked in this space
developing genoma and gene expression
based test for active surveillance it's
important that everybody know that
neither I nor anybody if the Cleveland
Clinic have any financial interest in
any of these companies or anything that
I'm going to talk about so let's talk
about active surveillance let me say
that active surveillance has been
gaining Traction in the United States in
the last several years and so I'll start
with a disclaimer um it's my belief that
most men with very low risk or almost
all men with very low risk and most men
with low risis disease and even some men
with intermediate risk prostate cancer
are appropriately and safely managed
with active
surveillance and if you agree with that
and if you already put most or all of
your patients with these characteristics
on surveillance then you're not going to
need the tools that I'm talking about so
my message today is for those of you who
are reluctant to put your patients on
surveillance because of your fears over
really predicting what the underlying
tumor biology is for each patient and
understanding how to follow them and so
those fears are widespread there are two
recent Publications that look at the
penetrat of active surveillance and the
management of very low and low rist
disease one is from the capture registry
which is a conglomerate of academic and
some sophisticated private practice uh
institutions and if you look on the very
right hand side of the slide in the most
recent years that were measured 2010
through 2013 and you look at the solid
dot you can see that the use of active
surveillance has uh increased in this
population to about 40% which is
absolutely terrific the problem is that
the individuals who are part of the
capture registry are highly motivated to
do this and if you look at a broader
database covering only patients with
very lowrisk cancer those who are uh
ideally managed by surveillance and you
look at a broader database the National
Cancer database you can see that
nationally fewer than 10% of all
patients who should go on surveillance
actually go on surveillance and so what
both of these slides tell us is that
there is significant room for
improvement in terms of the use of
active surveillance and we have to
understand why people don't put why
practitioners don't put more people on
surveillance and I believe it's mostly a
fundamental anxiety over not being able
to PR predict an individual's biologic
potential at the time of uh diagnosis so
let's talk about what active
surveillance version 1.0 looks like I'll
talk about two recent Publications one
from Toronto and one from Baltimore that
show us that active surveillance is safe
for most patients but highlight the role
of precision medicine so in improving it
and making uh making it next generation
so this is the current Paradigm when we
see a patient who has an initial biopsy
and they're Cate categorized as very low
lower intermediate risk disease we look
at their comorbidities and life
expectancy and patient desire and up
until recently we generally have
re-evaluated those patients to be sure
that the initial biopsy didn't miss
higher grade cancer that would
disqualify them from surveillance and
again until the last year or two I would
say at least in our practice that meant
everybody had a second biopsy soon after
the first because we know that initial
biopsy has a significant sampling error
and if the patient were a candidate for
surveillance then in version 1.0 he
would be re re-evaluated periodically
for a change in Risk categorization so
we would see him every six months and do
a digital rectal exam in PSA we
generally speaking have followed the
Hopkins Paradigm and biopsy everybody
once a year and if someone's cancer was
treading water as I tell them still
remain low grade and low volume Le in
six they stay on surveillance but there
were progression uh in uh in the
broadest sense of the term to higher
grade cancer uh where they mooved from
very low to low risk or they mooved from
low to intermediate risk or their PSA
were going up or the patient decided
that he no longer wanted to undergo the
biopsies or was worried then we would
intervene that's what surveillance 1.0
looks like we have two great series now
that tell us that this is safe to do for
most patients this is data from laor
classus Series in Toronto demonstrating
that roughly for a thousand patients who
were put on surveillance that the death
rate due to prostate cancer at 15 years
was only 6% and you can see out of a
thousand patients roughly there were 15
deaths and 13 developed metastatic
disease so overall you could say that
for every thousand patients who went on
surveillance using his relatively loose
criteria which included some men with
grade three plus fours and where the
triggers for biopsy were based at least
in part at the beginning on TSA velocity
and where everybody wasn't biopsy year
the patients did pretty well and in fact
if you were to look at the data in his
series you were nine times more likely
to die of something other than prostate
cancer if you went on surveillance then
you were prostate cancer but I have some
concerns about that data that illustrate
not that surveillance isn't a good idea
for most patients just that it isn't
perfect and that as we think about
inventing Next Generation active
surveillance there's the opportunity to
apply the Precision medicine approach to
improve this and get the decision right
for every patient so here's one of my
concerns of the men who had intervention
and there were a little under 300 I
think who had
intervention half of them had
biochemical failure after radiation or
surgery at 15 years why is that a
problem you've all had this conversation
with the patient which is someone who's
reluctant to go on surveillance and
you're really you really think it's the
right thing to do and um you're
counseling them and they say are you
certain can you look me in the eye are
you certain that if my cancer gets a
little worse and if few years that I can
still be cured and in order to convince
a patient for surveillance we have to
honestly answer that question yes well
this data suggests that that in fact is
not true and it's not that these men
with biochemical failure 15 years after
treatment are going to die of prostate
cancer but some of them will go on to
get secondary therapies like radiation
therapy or hormones and some will go on
to develop metastasis and again all I'm
suggesting is not that surveillance
isn't good for these patients it's just
that we can do better and we need to
have better tools that allow us to
qualify patients more accurately for
surveillance at the beginning and to
follow them to know when to pull the
trigger while they're on surveillance
some other cautions that I have um in
both series as I showed you the number
of patients who were followed for more
than 10 to 15 years is actually quite
small the median followup in the in the
kot series is only six and a half years
and as I'll show you in the Hopkins
series it's only five years so I think
we need longer term data but let's do
the math if you were to take L's data
for for every thousand men there were 15
deaths and 13 who develop metastasis
that means for every 10,000 who go on
surveillance using his criteria and
follow up there'd be 150 deaths and 130
who get metastasis and for every 100,000
it's 1500 and 1300 and so if you think
about this and project what we might do
in the United States for the next 10
years this is a very reasonable
assumption if we were to take all this
data and say surveillance is the right
thing for most patients as a group of
urologists in the United States we're
going to put 100,000 many year for the
next 10 years on surveillance so that's
a million men well what happens if we do
that there are 15,000 deaths and 13,000
men who get metastatic disease and while
it's true that they would have avoided
the acute treatment related side effects
in my experience most patients would
rather go through those side effects and
avoid the risk of death or metastasis
and so that's an important conversation
that you have to have with each patient
each will make their own decision but
again this illustrates to me that
there's an opportunity to Pro to use
genomic testing to better identify these
patients who might run into trouble and
either disqualify them from surveillance
from the beginning and treat them or to
detect when their cancer progresses
while they're on surveillance and
intervene before uh they run into a
problem and so this is the Hopkins data
which used much stricter criteria for
entry these were only very low and
lowrisk patients no intermediate risk
patients and you can see roughly again
it's a little over a, patients in the
blue line you were far more likely to
die of other causes than prostate cancer
if you went on surveillance using this
and here are the data for each of the
risk categories very lowrisk and lowrisk
but if you look at the bullet point
showing overall there were five men out
of 1300 who developed metastatic disease
and only two who died of prostate cancer
and that's really quite convincing that
most men with very low and low risk
disease ought to go on surveillance and
again what stands out is that most men
in the United States despite this great
data showing it safe don't go on
surveillance so the tools I'm going to
talk about again are to help
practitioners push patients uh toward
the right thing which is surveillance
now there was a cost in the Hopkins
series for achieving these results and
here's the cost annual biopsy in all of
these patients and what I've learned in
my practice on annual on in active
surveillance is that annual biopsy is
costly um it occasionally causes
significant problems which we'll talk
about in a minut
and it isn't necessary in every patient
I really believe that as we have these
tools now that really reveal what the
biology of the tumor is that we can tell
who's progressing while they're on
surveillance and who isn't and no one to
pull the trigger in a far better fashion
than we know now and that's going to be
part of what I call Active surveillance
version 2.0 which I'll show you at the
end of my talk so here are the cautions
from the Hopkins series again the median
followup was only five years and you can
see only 26 patients were followed for
15 years the biochemical failure rate
after intervention was only 8% as
compared to 50% in the Toronto series
and again that relates to the fact that
there were stricter selection criteria
in the Hopkins series and patients were
followed far more closely with biopsy
and overall two thats and five
metastases so let's do the math here and
the numbers look far better with
stricter criteria and stricter follow-up
for 10,000 patients it's only 20 men who
die and 50 who get metastatic disease
for 100,000 it's 200 to 500
and again if you put those 100,000 men a
year on surveillance for 10 years a
million men it's 2,000 and 5,000 now
those are great data again I find them
very convincing that most men with very
low or low risk disease should go on
surveillance but it's not perfect and we
need to be able to do better and
so the question comes then as you look
at this data is active surveillance good
or bad well it's good if you're not one
of those men who develop metastasis or
die while on surveillance and on a
population basis the numbers are so
favorable that if you were designing for
example the the Health Care system on
managing prostate cancer for a whole
province in Canada or for a state or for
a country you would say surveillance is
the way to go but I believe that on an
individual basis there's room for
improvement in case selection and our
goal ought to be not to get it right for
most patients but to get it right for
every patient and that's where Precision
medicine tools come in and I believe
that these tools can refine individual
biologic risk risk that can help us at
all the steps during surveillance that I
showed before and there are some other
limitations of surveillance how often do
we really need to
rebiopsy patients I have many patients
that I biopsied on a yearly basis where
the biopsy is repeatedly negative or it
again only shows one core of lowgrade
glein six cancer and I always wonder if
putting the patient through that was
really necessary the problems with
biopsy this is a recent report from uh
Australia that uh looked at um the
national sample of biopsies over a 5year
period 34,000 biopsies and you can see
there was almost a 2% biopsy related
readmission rate uh at a cost of about
us $7,000 per case and there was one
death and so it suggests to me that as
we invent active surveillance 2.0 and
think carefully about this that we can
use these new tools to do fewer biopsies
and that is certainly something the
patients will like but it also is safer
and less cost ly do all patients need to
be followed at the same intensity if you
have a patient who starts out with low
Vine greas and six disease and has a
very favorable biologic score agenomic
scor gen expression score my suggestion
is that that patient doesn't need to be
nearly followed with nearly the same
intensity as someone let's say who has
higher Vine glein six disease who's more
likely to Harbor glein 7 disease that
was missed by biopsy and that's someone
who could be one of those who was
destined to progress and develop
metastasis or die that we ought not see
those patients at the same interval the
first patient could be followed less
closely and the latter patient needs to
be followed more closely and then I
think that we don't really know when to
pull the trigger and I'll show you a
couple of examples in a minute on on uh
how to uh or rather what the Dilemma is
there but I think we could use these
tools to decide when to intervene and
and prevent that so and and I will again
emphasize to you not that I think this
is worrisome data in the sense that we
shouldn't do surveillance but we need to
keep in the back of our mind that when
we promise a patient that they go on
surveillance that we can still cure them
if they progress we're not 100% there
depending upon the criteria it could be
as high as 50% failure rate or it could
be low as low as 8% for those with the
with the most minimal biologically
indolent tumors at the cost of having a
biopsy every year while you're being
followed so let's talk about two typical
clinical scenarios that will illustrate
what the role of these Precision
medicine tools are these are real
patients for my practice a healthy
6-year-old Man based on Social Security
life expectancy has a long life
expectancy and he has very lowrisk
disease and if we were to do a radical
prostectomy on him theoretically he
could have favorable pathology and this
is what he's likely to have le in six
disease that's organ confined or low
volume Reon 3 plus4 this organ confined
and and we would say that we overtreat
him but we know from experience that
about 20% of patients who meet these
very lowrisk or Epstein criteria
actually have what we considered to be
adverse pathology dominant pattern for
disease with or without extra prostatic
extension or gleon eight disease or
worse and currently our ability to
predict whether this patient if he were
to undergo a prostectomy were to fall
into the green box as opposed to the
purple or pink box on an individual
basis is quite limited the best we can
do and I'll show you the data a little
bit later is to predict that he has an
80% chance of being in the green box and
having favorable pathology and a 20%
chance of having adverse pathology
wouldn't it be nice to have a biologic
tool that increases the accuracy of our
prediction that the patient has
favorable or unfavorable pathology
that's what these new tools can do and
so this gentleman just for illustrative
purposes happened to have a
prostatectomy and it turns out that he
was in the pink Fox and as I have given
this talk to many urologists across the
country and I asked the question if you
knew before you operated on this patient
if you knew that he was in the pink box
with adverse pathology would you um
offer this patient active surveillance
and in almost 100% of cases urologists
say no they wouldn't so if we do for
sure the individual had adverse
pathology we wouldn't put them on
surveillance if he were in the green box
we certainly would offer it to him and
then depending upon the patient's Age
and comorbidities and his desire he
would be a great candidate for
surveillance here's another scenario
where these new Precision medicine tools
can help us again a younger patient
healthy real patient um also has very
low RIS disease and he goes on
surveillance and a year after his
initial biopsy which shows one of 12
cores with glein 6 disease he now has
glein 3 plus4 disease in one of 12 cores
and so the question is that we always
scratch our head about is this under
sampling was that grade seven cancer
there previously and just missed by the
initial biopsy is this true progression
or is this variability and pathologic
Inter interpretation all of us have had
the experience where we have two
different Pathologists both of whom are
excellent clinicians look at a biopsy
and one calls a GLE and six and one C
calls a GLE and seven one of the
problems is with surveillance is that we
can't distinguish between these spot
three possibilities for these patients
and I hope to demonstrate to you how
using a biologic tool can prevent that
so here's the real issue here you've all
seen this sort of slide this is a
cross-section home Mount of a radical
crossectomy specimen and we know that
there are multiple tumors in most
prostates and we know that there's
variability or heterogenity in grade and
we know that the biopsy often Only Hits
the lowgrade disease and so we're trying
to develop ways of looking at the entire
prostate the biology of the entire
prostate even though we only have
lowgrade disease and so the two
questions that arise are how well does
recent grade predict true biologic
potential that's one issue and I believe
that there's a subset of grade six
tumors that are pure grade six that do
have some biologic potential probably on
the order of five to 10% of them and
then how accurately does the biopsy
capture the biology of the whole
prostate those are the those are the
issues that we have and so I'm going to
talk now about the development of
archetype DX made by genomic health and
there are some other products on the
market prolis and promark which I don't
have any personal experience with
although we did some of the validation
studies with promar and I don't have a
particular favor I'm going to talk about
archetyp DX because we help develop it
at the clevand clinic because it's the
one that I use and that I know best and
because I think it has some advantages
to the others and so in order to get to
address the question of how can you
capture the biology of the whole
prostate just based on a biopsy that
shows low-grade cancer we did an initial
experiment where we took 500 radical
prostatectomy specimens one of which you
see here in whom we had 15 to 20 year
followup on these patients have we micro
disected the low grade pattern three and
the high-grade pattern four tumor and we
asked the question if you sample the
right genes on these biopsies looking at
RNA expression gene expression if you
sample the right genes could you find
genes that predict who got metastatic
diseased and who died and the answer to
that question was yes and then we asked
the question if you looked at the right
genes did it matter whether you samp
them in the low grade or the high grade
tumor and surprisingly the answer was no
if you look at the right genes it
doesn't matter whether you look only at
the lowgrade tumor uh you can still
predict what happens to the patient and
that was the experiment that we did and
so how can that be this is a little bit
of biology now which I won't dwell on
but I want to explain this because it's
important that everybody understand this
we've all been taught appropriately that
every individual clone of a tumor every
individual cell almost or nest of cells
has its own genetic biology and that's
absolutely true they all have their own
private mutations that you see in that
structure on the very right which looks
like a tree with branches but what we've
learned in the recent years is that
there also are some trunco mutations or
trun changes in gene expression that are
shared in common by all the tumor clones
and so if you measure the right biology
if you measure the truncal mutations or
the trunco gene expression you can
capture a common underlying biology that
is reflective of everything that's going
on in the prostate and another way to
think about this is this if you think
about the difference between a smart car
and a Tesla they both have very
different potentials one's sexy and fun
to drive one goes fast one doesn't go
fast it doesn't go so far the interior
appointments are nicer in one or the
other but you know intuitively by
looking at them that they're both cars
how do you know that they both have
wheels they both have steering wheels
they both have passenger seats and
driver seats and they both have engines
and so those are the trunco mutations or
the trunco gene Expressions that
characterize the essence of those cars
well if you think back to tumors again
all the tumors that we have looked at
and I believe this is true for most
prostate cancer perhaps not in 100% of
cases but in a in a substantial
majority that they have a common
underlying biology that can be measured
by biopsy even just the lowgrade cancer
that's what our data shows so that
brings us back to the whole Mount
prostatectomy specimen where we're
looking at our problem and the way
archetype DX was described is the biopsy
only samples the lowgrade tumor but
because we're looking at the trunco
common underlying biology we can measure
the biology of the whole prostate and
you can immediately see how this
intuitively can help us select patients
for active surveillance because if you
biopsy the patient and you only have
lowgrade tumor but it has molecular
characteristics of a higher grade tumor
that's someone who's going to be in that
pink box someone who who has adverse
pathology and if they're young and
healthy and have a long life expectancy
they probably shouldn't go on active
surveillance so this is the promise of
genomic approaches and this is a
hypothetical construct that suggests
that within each risk category very low
low and intermediate risk category
there's actually a spread of risk it's
not that everybody in each category has
the same risk you have some patients who
have favorable biology illustrated by
the green dots and some patients who
have unfavorable biology illustrated by
red dots within each risk category and
so genomics in the way that I just
talked about can separate this man with
lowrisk disease who actually has very
favorable biology from this man who also
has only low-risk disease based on PSA
grade and stage but actually has
unfavorable biology and again if they're
young and healthy the man on the left
with the in the Green Dot should be a
good candidate for surveillance and
perhaps the man on the right shouldn't
be so I mentioned the other available
markers uh on the market and although
they predict other things the ones that
are useful for active surveillance that
they all are biopsy based predictors for
adverse pathology and by that I mean
what's in the pink box dominant pattern
for disease we all know that patients
who have dominant pattern for disease
even if they have a prostate Tech
radiation therapy or at higher risk of
disease recurrence and death it's not
that th those patients aren't cured in
large measure they are but those are the
patients who are at larger at at higher
risk and the same is true for
extraprostatic detention or gr eight
disease all of these tools that are on
the
market help us more accurately predict
who's in this purple box and who has
adverse pathology and therefore adverse
biology and who aren't good candidates
for surveillance so I mentioned this
earlier the question arises now how good
are we are we predicting who's in the
green box with favorable pathology and
who's in the pink box with unfavorable
pathology currently well the answer is
not as good as we think we're not 100%
accurate and that's the goal of
Precision medicine is to get the
decision right for every patient at the
start of surveillance and Al throughout
all the processes of surveillance and so
this is a large Pros detect from from
ckins that was published about two years
ago that shows us how accurate or
inaccurate we are so you can see for
very lowrisk disease NCC and very low
risk disease or Epstein criteria we only
accurately predict who's in the green
box 80% of the time and so you can have
very low risk disease and you have a one
in five chance of having adverse
pathology and for not a good candidate
for surveillance if you're young and
healthy and for low risk disease we're
only accurate about 70% of the time and
I estimate although it's not from this
data that for intermediate risk disease
we're only accurate about 50 to 60% of
the time so these tools can improve on
these individual predictions that
increase our accuracy for each of these
and I'll illustrate some case examples
from my practice later in the talk to
show you how to use these and how they
improve accuracy these are the uh genes
that are archetyp DX prostate uh there
are 12 cancer related genes and five
reference genes it's not important that
you know what they are it is important
that you recognize that they measure a
broad biology four different Pathways
that drive cancer and what did these
genes predict for well if you measure
them if you measure their expression on
prostatectomy specimens they predict for
metastasis and death more importantly
and in an experiment that I haven't
described to you when you measure them
on biopsy whether it has pattern three
or pattern four on the biopsy it
predicts for adverse pathology it
predicts who's in that purple box who
shouldn't go on surveillance if they're
young and healthy it predicts for
dominant pattern for disease or disease
outside the prostate as defined by
extraprostatic extension semov vesical
Invasion or lyth node metastasis and
again if you had a patient in your
office who had a biopsy that shows only
Loi Rees and six disease but you knew
that they had dominant pattern for
disease or one of these other adverse
features you wouldn't put them on
surveillance that's what these tools can
help so after we did our biopsy study we
went to some collaborators at the
University of California San Francisco
Pete Carrol and that cooperberg and
asked them to repeat the experiment they
took 400 men who'd had biopsy and
prostatectomy in San Francisco and we
asked them to to test how well antip BX
predicted the presence of these adverse
pathologic features and what I'll show
you is a remarkable spread of scores
among each category so these are
patients who meet Epstein criteria nccn
very low risk and you can see the
scatter in the scores there you can see
that not everybody clusters in the
middle not everybody with very lowrisk
disease actually when you measure the
biology using anet type DX has the same
uh risk of of adverse pathology and you
can see way out to the right that there
are two green dots men who had very
lowrisk disease but who actually
biologically have a high likelihood of
having worst in biology and probably
aren't good candidates for surveillance
and the same thing was true for patients
with low risk disease and interestingly
it was true for patients who had a
certain kind of intermediate risk
disease low and glein 3 plus4 and biopsy
what this data suggests to me is that
that hypothetical construct I showed you
a few slides ago with the yellow arrows
and the green dots and the red dots is
actually real it's not a hypothetical
construct within each of these clinical
risk categories there's a real spread of
biologic risk and we can exploit this in
information in a way that helps us make
more informed decisions so if you have
very low or lowrisk disease and you have
a low likelihood of having adverse
pathology all the dots that are to the
middle and to the left good candidate
for surveillance and if you have very
low or lowest disease and you're young
and healthy and have 20 years ahead of
you or 25 years ahead of you and you're
one of the dots that are out on the
right you're probably not a good
candidate for sur but look with the
intermediate risk there's a big spread
and there are a lot of men with
intermediate risk disease who have a
very low risk based on the GPS score
that you see on the x-axis of having uh
really biologically aggressive cancer
and this suggests to me I think it's
revealing that there are many men with
glein 3 plus4 disease low Vine who have
very favorable biology and are good
candidates for surveillance and that
would of course be older men who may
have some comorbidities I'm not sure I
would recommend that for a 50-year-old
with intermediate rist disease
nonetheless it identifies some patients
who have criteria that are usually used
to exclude patients from surveillance
that when you look at the biology
actually we should be more inclusive so
I'm going to show you the so same data
from the San Francisco validation study
in a slightly different way each dot
here represents one patient from these
400 in clinical categories very low risk
low risk and intermediate risk disease
and here's what happens when you add the
um biologic information I'm sorry I went
back on the slide let me move forward
here
and so here's what happens you add anet
type DX and you can see that a
substantial number of patients with low
risk disease biologically actually have
very low risk disease that should
increase the patient's confidence and
your confidence that those are great
candidates for surveillance and that
you're not missing worrisome cancer that
you wouldn't want to follow and there's
a smaller percentage of patients with
lowrisk disease that you might have
otherwise considered for surveillance
who actually have intermediate risk
disease if they're young and have a long
life expectancy
probably not good candidates for
surveillance if they're older and have
some comorbidities you still might
consider them for surveillance there are
a couple of patients with very low risk
disease not nearly as many who change
risk categorization and I showed you
those two green dots earlier those are
men who are not good candidates for
surveillance in my view and there are
even some men with intermediate risk
disease who actually biologically have
lowrisk disease who again depending upon
their individual circumstances might
therefore be a good candidate for
surveillance so if you just consider men
with low risk disease all those yellow
dots are men in your office that look
the same to you they all had three cores
of grease and six cancer PSAs of five
and normal feeling prostates and you
don't know how to distinguish one for
the other well the biologic tool that we
now have can separate these patients
into those with biologically very
lowrisk disease great candidates for
surveillance lowrisk disease probably
good candidates for surveillance where
intermediate risk disease again
depending upon their age and
comorbidities maybe not such a good
candidate for surveillance and that
improves our ability to select patients
Beyond grade stage in PSA it doesn't
replace grade stage in PSA or clinical
judgment or comorbidities or age or life
expectancy but it adds to it and allows
us to make more accurate predictions so
when we started this work our goal was
to change Behavior I showed you that
nationally fewer than 10% of el eligible
patients are going on surveillance well
what's happened since this tool these
tools have been available on the market
Market there are two practice pattern
studies that have been published now one
was primarily in lput type Private
Practice groups which showed when when
these practitioners started using
archetyp DX in this instance that the
percentage of patients who went on
surveillance increased dramatically and
what was really remarkable and I think
highly appropriate was that the number
of patients who went on surveillance
increased for each risk category very
low low and even intermediate risk
disease and I was pleased to see that
because that was the goal of developing
these tests to begin with which is to
increase the number of eligible patients
on surveillance and there was another uh
prospective study that uh included
mostly academic centers and a few
private centers that showed the same
thing that the absolute increase in use
of active surveillance was about 10%
which is a move in the right direction
so let me conclude my uh talk with a
couple of case examples and then show
you what I think active surveillance
version 2.0 really ought to look like I
want to remind you before I show you the
case examples of how accurate or
inaccurate we are using grade stage and
PSA to predict who is in that pink box
with favorable pathology remember these
are patients newly diagnosed that had
one biopsy that shows low-grade cancer
and you're trying to decide whether or
not they're candidate for surveillance
if we use just the information we have
now without the biologic information we
get it right 80% of the time for very
lowrisk disease 70% of the time for
lowrisk disease and about 60% of the
time for inter immediate risk disease so
again these are all real cases a young
man long life expectancy he has very low
risk disease here you see his biopsy Le
3 plus 3 one out of six cor is 30% 3
millimeters based on the information
that's on the slide he has an 80% chance
of favorable pathology there are a lot
of urologists and many patients who
think that that's not good enough and
they end up getting treated and many of
them about 80% of them will be
overtreated well here's this anet type
score if you look on the left where it
says likelihood of favorable path ology
he actually has an 88% chance of
favorable pathology that's an absolute
increase of 8% compared to what we would
have predicted based on grade stage in
PSA and it's a relative increase of 10%
so to me this makes our decision-making
about 10% more accurate and in my view
he's a great candidate for surveillance
and that's what he did so let me compare
two cases this should be case 2A and 2B
and look at the pat look at patient B
first he has low V increas in six
disease and look at patient a about the
same age about the same PSA and he has
higher ble and six disease and when I
show this to most neurologist most
everybody says yeah would consider
surveillance for patient B but not for
patient a because he has higher blind Le
and six well they both have lowrisk
disease which would predict a 70%
likelihood of being in the pink box of
having favorable pathology well here are
their side bys side entite scores
patient a actually moves from low to
very low risk with a likelihood of
favorable pathology that's actually
about 81% instead of predicted 70% and
patient B who had lower volume tumor
actually is in the intermediate risk
category he's one of those yellow dots
who moved into the red zone that I
showed you a couple slides ago so
patient a went on surveillance and it's
actually been on surveillance for two
years now without sign of progression
patient B actually went on to have a
prostatectomy and he had a grade seven
cancer with focal extraprostatic
extension now some people get upset when
I show this and say well you would have
picked up his progression on his next
biopsy and he might not have died or had
a PSA recurrence and that might be
true but I will again emphasize to you
on a population basis even using the
strictest selection criteria and annual
biopsies in the Hopkins series 8% of
patients who had intervention later were
not
cured here's the third case this is a
pretty dramatic case a 75-year-old
physician who um came to see me after
he'd finally been biopsy you can see his
characteristics there look at his biopsy
less than 1 millimeter poli's 3 plus4
disease in a 75y old so his Actuarial
life expectancy is just about 10 years
the likelihood of him dying from a gleis
3 plus4 line cancer is virtually zero
and he meets intermediate risk criteria
and I really counseled him and tried to
push him toward surveillance and he
insisted that he wanted to be treated
and I said let's do an archetype DX and
we'll see who's right and he is right
here's his archetype DX which predicted
a high likelihood 50% chance of having
adverse pathology and here's his
prostatectomy was 8 with extra prostatic
extension really remarkable um that the
biology was able to be correctly
assessed based on less than one
millimeter of tumor on the biopsy and
that really shows how powerful this
technology is and he's done well after
his prostatectomy so many of you are
probably wondering well why not re just
biopsy everybody a second time why do we
need this fancy expensive genomic test I
think genomic testing is better because
no patient who's had one biopsy wants to
have another
one a second biopsy is subject to the
same sampling error it doesn't get it
right all biopsies have a risk of
serious infection and even death and
more importantly and I think this is
underappreciated genome it's are
objectives okay we all have great
Pathologists but the pathologist only
can read the information that's in front
of them and there's a fair amount of
variability in gas and scoring biology
is not dependent upon pathologic
expertise and so if we use these tests
widely to determine eligibility for men
on before they start surveillance you
could more often get it right because
you have an objective read of the
biology that's not dependent on the
local expertise of your pathologist and
what about Mr let me confess my bias and
say that we are fans of Mr we we use it
all the time now but if you think about
what Mr does compared to what a genomic
test does when you're considering
putting a patient on surveillance I
think a genomic test is a better choice
and here's why Mr makes biopsy better
but it's not perfect so Mr doesn't see
all tumors some of the data that I'm
showing there on the right there are
three published theories now that show
that Mr misses about 15% of grade seven
or higher tumors and the practice
patterns in the US the most grade seven
tumors get treated in the US and not
followed and so Mr doesn't seal all
tumors so if you rely only on Mr you're
going to be wrong 15% % of the time Mr
increases the likelihood of finding a
recent seven cancer but it can't tell
you if it needs to be treated and I
think I've shown you pretty convincing
data from the biopsy series and this is
from our prostate series these cap Meer
curves that show in the green line that
there are about 15% of men with
intermediate risk disease who actually
had very favorable biology and can go on
surveillance wouldn't it be wonderful if
we could reduce over treatment of those
men by using genomic tests Mr has no
long-term follow-up data in the
surveillance population that will change
with time but at present it doesn't and
the data that I showed you on our
prostate techy series we have 20-year
follow-up on the ability of genomics to
predict metastasis or death and finally
and importantly just like biopsy
genomics are objective and not operator
dependent there are lots of Private
Practice Urology groups in the country
who don't have Mr Fusion biopsy
available because they can't afford the
equipment and they don't have the
radiologic expertise and I can tell you
from personal experience it takes some
practice there's a learning curve to
doing this correctly genomic doesn't
need that all you need is the biopsy
that has the cancer on it and you can
get an objective read of what the
biology of the patient is so what does
all this mean what does active
surveillance 2.0 look like well here's
the current Paradigm which I showed
early in the talk let me show you how
active surveillance 2.0 might happen
with a genomic based Paradigm at the
beginning there's no change we still see
patients who have lowrisk disease or
very low risk disease or intermediate
risk disease come to the office and say
what should I do and we still need to
consider their comorbidities and life
expectancy and their desire and so forth
but when we want to consider whether or
not they're really a candidate for
surveillance we can reduce the burden of
determining eligibility by substituting
a biomarker for a second biopsy that
allows an objective read of the biology
and um also if you use for example anet
type DX or promar can tell you about the
biology of the entire prostate we also
can improve patient selection so
we all have had patients who have very
lowrisk disease who are reluctant to go
on surveillance because they're worried
that their cancer will progress to
metastized before they can be cured if
they have a favorable score we can
increase their confidence and our
confidence that surveillance is safe on
the flip side there are occasional
patients who have low risk disease even
very low risk disease who want to go on
surveillance but whose biology really is
more worrisome than they should and in
those patients we can increase
acceptance both for ourselves and the
patients the treatment is warranted and
and that the side effects are warranted
and I have used these tests in that
manner several times we also I believe
can change the intensity of monitoring I
don't have data to support this yet but
it makes sense and I throw it out there
as a testable hypothesis if you have a
patient who decides to go on
surveillance and has a very favorable
score he probably doesn't need to be as
monitored as intensely as someone with
an unfavorable score who despite that
decides to go on surveillance so again
the the difference between a patient
with one core of glein six with one
millimeter of cancer versus five cores
of glein six with a couple millimeters
of cancer I believe biologically those
are different patients we should pay
more attention to the latter patient
than the former one and we can use these
sorts of tools to even identify those
who have even lower BBL and six disease
who need to be followed more uh
intensely and in whom we can intervene
and then finally uh we can do something
that's called seral biologic monitoring
again I don't have data on this but it
is being studied prospectively where we
can develop a way of deciding when to
pull the trigger so you think back to
that clinical scenario I showed you case
number two where the man went from gleon
6 one out of 12 cores went on
surveillance and a year later has one
core of GLE 3 plus4 is that true
biologic progression well we don't have
the tools to know that now and most of
those patients end up getting treated
although I suspect many of them are
overtreated um we can use these
uh tools on a Serial basis measuring
their biology on their initial biopsy
and then on their subsequent biopsy two
or three two or three years later to
help decide when to pull the trigger so
I'm let me conclude with this
perspective we're on the threshold of a
new genomic based Precision man medicine
Paradigm for prostate cancer that I am
quite excited about these biomarkers add
to but don't replace standard predictors
of outcome this is very important grade
stage and PSA still matter age of the
patient comorbidities life expectancies
still matter what the patient wants to
do still matters but these biomarkers
allow us if we use them to make more
accurate decisions and to give our both
ourselves and patients information that
allow more informed decisions these are
first generation asay that improved
decision- making now will get better
with additional iterations and the the
um analogy I use here is if you look at
your cell phone and what it can
accomplish compared to your very first
desktop computer there's magnitudes of
difference and with the genomic
technology that's evolving 10 years from
now I think we'll be in the same place
and we ought to develop the competency
with the first tools that we have now to
get used to them I do think that the
first generation tools make us better
decision makers but I also firmly
believe that additional uh iterations
are going to make these better and then
finally and most importantly getting a
clinical decision right the first time
is always the most cost-effective
approach people worry about what the
cost of these are and I would say to you
that getting the decision right from the
patient whether it's surveillance
whether it's immediate treatment whether
it's knowing when to pull the trigger is
always the most cost-effective approach
so I leave you with a wonderful picture
of Cleveland on the fourth of July I
thank you for your attention and very
pleased to take
questions thank you Dr Klein for
bringing that important information to
us great presentation I just want to
remind our audience before we get
started with any questions that here's
how they can reach us today questions
can be sent via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window and we do want to get to as many
questions as we can so I want to just
give our audience a second to find a
button and submit their questions for Dr
Klein very important information
presented here today and um there's a
lot to take
in
okay I'm just uh I'm to keep an eye on
our
CU all righty then I see that we don't
have any questions today so I would
again like to thank Dr Klein for his
time and uh also thank L GRS for
bringing this presentation to us Dr
Klein do you have any further comments
final
comments you know I was just reflecting
on this Fourth of July picture there and
how exciting that can be that's how
excited I am about all of this new
technology and our improved ability to
manage
patients very true very true today's
webcast I want to let an audience know
will be available for on demand viewing
through March 2016 and receive an email
from us alerting when it's available on
demand and posted on liat.com we hope
that you will forward this announcement
to any colleagues who weren't able to
join in today thank you again for
logging in and participating in today's
broadcast we'll see you next
time